okay tip and out what would they say no
fool is pronounce the stupid people get
yo [ __ ] together man
[Music]
Oh what's going on YouTube check it out
so I have come to the conclusion that um
there are way too many stupid people in
this world and what the hell do I mean
by stupid people I'm not gonna base
intelligence on whether you have a
college degree or not or whether you
chose the traditional route of schooling
I'm talking about straight idiots not
before I go ahead and talk about a
certain friend of mine I know that
you'll get our asses watching this video
and I don't care what you think you may
put my ass at the end of the day but
just you know you just give me a head
start this fool is so stupid I help you
sign up for a job application and the
age of 28 on the job application it asks
what was your previous occupation his
ghetto ass bro I'm used to bein cuz that
wasn't even the worst part the worst
part was when he looked at me and he
said hey dumb at the end of says please
attach your resume what does that mean
pursue [ __ ] you-me resume - my dumb
folks out there let me give you some
advice on how to not sound like a idiot
on a daily basis so you already know
what it is LG
[Music]
you know how people say there's no such
thing as a stupid question
sigh they're wrong you know who says
that stupid people there are plenty of
stupid questions that you can ask for
example if I'm at a restaurant why would
you ask for Mario baby what are you
doing here [ __ ] I'm eating you know
what's worse is that when I'm taking the
piss and I'm in the urinal and you ask
what am i doing what does it look like
I'm doing
don't don't talk to another guy what is
what is thank you
eyes appear eyes appear if you don't
know an answer to a question
don't act like you do do you know how I
know this is I used to do back in the
day I used to kick it with some bit knee
studs and they would always talk about
the car parts which I always acted like
I knew what they were talking about
however I didn't know you want to see my
car it got a little cooler Oh word you
gotta cool it you got it you out of your
refrigerator in your car that's could
you just drink and drive that's not
responsible you back my check no man
what the hell you saved my day so read a
book [ __ ] please just anything read a
book from time to time stimulate java
mine and don't just tell people that you
read books because we obviously can tell
that you don't and you know who you damn
well are you people out there on
Facebook some of you get a last people
who I know do not read always put on
your favorite section the books I just
read let me tell you something
unless Shakespeare is another word for
back of a noodle packet [ __ ] you don't
read talk about New Thought resume was a
French word for resume [ __ ] you must be
able to cut their mind do you know
what's worse than a dumbass it's a
dumbass that actually thinks he or she
is smarter because you could never
convince this type of idiot that they're
wrong it's damn near impossible back in
the day I used to know this guy I won't
say his name but he used to always get
advice because he thought that everybody
was mean muggin his ass
hey yo Thank You chef oh yeah even be
muggy be all night
uh whoo there's nobody else here but you
me that full right there with the blue
shirt in the gray cap
whoo mother that mother [ __ ] that's
the mirror that's your reflection
anyways people it's a very sad thing
nowadays there and look around I see a
lot of people who choose to be
uneducated in this country we have
something called free education which is
an amazing thing and a lot of us really
chew
not utilize it and just because you
choose a route not to go to school it
doesn't mean that you should just dumb
yourself up educate yourself be well
first read a mother but if you happy
being stupid then that's fine by me
I just don't open your mouth and spread
your stupidity out to other people
because if you do you should just lock
yourself in a porta potty and drown
yourself huh
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
you know we know for making that pop
music right yeah
[Music]
what you should have taught them loud
ass Asian people [ __ ]